what you're looking at is a monster from
sump I got it in the cavalry
[Music]
to show that man is king Skull Island
rated pg-13 experience it in IMAX March
ends these are photos of an island in
the South Pacific the place where myth
of science means we use explosives to
shake the earth helping us to map the
surface of the island they're dropping
bombs scientific insurance
good I'm monkey
[Music]
magnificent
you knew that thing was out here I'm
sorry for your man girl but if you want
to make this sacrifice worthwhile get us
home
with proof monsters exist
[Music]
your friend there can put that down what
the hell is this place
that's calm he's King around here comes
pretty good King keeps to himself mostly
where you don't go into someone's house
and start dropping bombs unless you're
picking a fight call his God on the
island but the devil's live below us and
what if a calls
I call them skull crores why never said
that name out loud before it sounds
stupid now that I say just you call them
whatever you want
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here
you